[Music]
in royal embarrassment news submitted by
Song of Ice and Fire the princess all
the princess and the princesses vote for
that one what was that one what the
princess is one you're good go on and
Megan Merkel's dad was caught in a
paparazzi scandal and is no longer
attending the royal wedding
who's Megan bark oh yeah the bride yeah
she's the one that's about to marry
Prince Harry yeah this is Megan she's an
American Oh
actress she's the one above controversy
why cause she's not royal yeah because
no because she's hot black really like
the first black boy yeah that's time we
can't have a black royal that's what
they're saying
but I thought there's like royal black
Royals in Africa like bloodline is
written so white that this'll ruin
everything
ruin the bloodline to ruin a whole gym
yeah but she doesn't look that black
she's not inbred enough for this
bloodline they have to keep that in bred
purity and on a man like that [ __ ]
albino whiteness her teeth are two
extremes Yeah right it just looks too
nice no she's like what is it she's not
full black that's why half white
okay I miss she's Obama black Obama bag
but Obama looks more black she's also
Obama white mama why BAM all right so
her father named Thomas he was recently
in that so the royal kings and ten
palace or whatever they announced that
Kingdom two kings and Kings Intan is
that is it yeah did I say it wrong it's
Kings in town
you couldn't even troll you that long
he's in town Kings in town that's where
it is yeah yeah think about him though
he tried to tell you with the wrong
pronunciation that he couldn't handle it
and he just be confident with whatever
one will never be confident you guys
destroy my confident but with this [ __ ]
no we destroy what you're saying just
say whatever you want we don't destroy
the confidence we have your back yeah so
anyway the palace they announce them
which palette said where which pot you
see the palace of Wales they announce
said he will be walking his daughter
down the aisle on May 19th which is the
day of the royal wedding but they said
no cus cuz why cuz the paparazzi if you
stop interrupting I swear to you I love
you okay I'm ready for the information
all right
so TMZ recently reported that he will no
longer walk his daughter down the aisle
because it was surfaced that he recently
staged these paparazzi photos of him
like looking here I'll show you these
photos so well first of all here's a
throwback photo of them and this is her
dad this is Thomas and Megan he looks
like a this is her dad she's half black
and half white you know is it wrong for
me to assume that the dad's gonna be
black for some reason the mom is like I
know by some wrong why would that be
wrong huh I thought her dad looks half
white half black and then her mom is
also half white half black and then she
cuts you know you know but the dads have
black half white no moms half white half
black yeah please
so first of all they see how we're being
taken in he's American so Megan's
half-sister has come out saying that she
was the one that suggested the dad
staged these photos here because of
photos like this where he's being
presented in like wrong light like
buying fast food wait this is the
indigenous food of his people the white
are you talking about fried chicken yeah
or just just fast food
yeah it's American it related to Colonel
Sanders
apparently he staged these photos so him
doesn't look like a paparazzi took IV
course it doesn't how does it pop
probably get into your [ __ ] office
he's like these pain-in-the-ass paper
Aziz he's like I'll keep my window open
for him now that looked like a stock
photo of like he got green screen on
there and then like threw it in to like
yeah you got it you looking at news
articles about it's great his daughter
and the prince and so when these first
came out the media is saying that they
for the first reaction was like oh how
cute what he's like supportive of his
daughter looking at her they're going
that stupid and then this other one here
is images of Britain he's reading this
or looking at him and it's very like it
turned out to the camera it's still in
the planet like a bulldog reading he's
looking on the side of the book like
he's reading the crack of the book yeah
so this is another staged photo and then
of him getting like for his suit
tailored sizing happening thank you but
he won't be walking them down people
these were staged he was like you know
what I'm gonna save the family of more
embarrassment and I just won't show up
at all
and so now Meghan and Harry are very
distraught why did he staged all those
photos because the kids talked him into
it the half-sister make a tough sister
suggested to him like hey you should
have some photos out there in the press
to make you look in a better light so
she's saying like this is all my fault
but he is under so much stress
apparently he had a heart attack
recently too but it's not the stress
it's the [ __ ] KFC hey or that say
nothing wrong about chaos the kernel is
good to all of us that original recipe
man hmm that's that's the [ __ ] so sad
how like petty this stuff is that people
like cares so much about these things
that they just can't have a wedding dad
at the wedding now because
because of this cuz there's the public
because it makes the royal family look
bad that's what this [ __ ] that I hate
about this because nobody gives a [ __ ]
about the royal family at least the
media they're all just ornaments they're
not even they don't even do anything
they're not like don't have no power but
British care cuz we don't care we do
care it out here we care does your mama
care uh she knows about it I don't know
if she kept we don't really have that
conversation but it gets aired out here
and you don't give a [ __ ] I don't even
know why we care though my momma cared
about Diana and so did mine that's all
she's got I like her I'm like you don't
even know the [ __ ] because no she's
elegant she was against Illuminati yep
that's true and we were on the bridge
where she died in the tunnel B meet
under s we didn't even know we were just
walking around and it was like oh cool
president Diana and I were like oh this
is where she died damn Wow it was right
next to the crazy horse by the by the
[ __ ] Eiffel Tower yeah do they have
like an indicator there oh yeah like
we're just hanging out on a bridge
you're just talking and then we're
looking at all these things and people
are taking photos and it was like you're
there yeah there's just all is like
Princess Diana like pictures and [ __ ]
that's what theory about the JFK thing
if they literally have like a like an x
marks the spot like where he got shot
like in Dealey Plaza which is super
weird it's like here's where you died
the bed where Lincoln died and there's
like a blood stain still on the sheet
and then I kept it preserved in stones
like and the lady's like and there's a
blood stain yeah it's like they're
excited about it yeah yeah and the beds
were tiny back there like I don't he
didn't even fit on that bed for sure
no way I think the house across the
street from Ford Theatre in Washington
Betsy you got shot by John Wilkes Booth
that's true that's an unofficial story
all right they don't know there's a
conspiracy behind that's what I heard
that's why people say break a leg on
stage because after he shot
Abraham Lincoln he jumped off the
balcony and broke his leg he was on the
stage he fell on stage and he's broke
his leg in
we've been why do people say that to
wish people luck I don't know that's
weird
maybe because the shooter broke his leg
so it's like break a leg I'm gonna be
like John Wilkes Booth no that's weird
but no going back to the road everything
I remember though when the last world
wedding happened I was living in Mexico
at the time or visiting I think and even
in Mexico they were streaming that or
like broadcasting that lady diet
wouldn't you know
oh last world wedding maybe it was just
so fascinated at the fact that it's like
royalty now and it's like you get to see
a queen and a king like she's so very
princess that's like a big thing until
the other one she was a commoner and
then this one's also a Commodore right
yeah yeah not even British yeah but this
isn't the first time an American became
a princess in Europe there's been many
many times before but they were all
whiter than me also it's different this
is like kind of cool it's like when
Tiger Woods was in the US Open
everyone's like oh [ __ ] I'm really
turned it on in school we like watch the
US Open because there's always yeah yeah
cuz it was a black guy like golfing and
we're like holy [ __ ] black guys golden
turned on phone Obama yeah exactly
Oh crazy but but i but I I don't get the
big deal I guess other than that because
Prince Harry's like the Khloe Kardashian
then gives a [ __ ] like like Prince
William is gonna be king he's never
gonna be king but Khloe you'll never be
Queen Kim Kim's our queen that's true so
like that's our royalty by the way okay
[ __ ] line is our line these is the
Kardashians okay you got Kim at the top
of the heap right she's the queen she's
the queen and then everybody else is the
subjects like nobody gives a [ __ ]
even Kanye oh yeah it's a matriarchy
yeah it doesn't matriarchy but that's
interesting mm-hmm like her wedding is
only a few days away and like this being
announced it's just like I think I'm
just a little bit jealous because I want
to be the one that's celebrated not them
yeah I just I don't feel like they
deserve it but you do Joe yep
yeah wake me up when Kim Kardashian gets
married again then I don't care
yeah they don't watch it and don't cry
oh yeah but uh but every time I watch it
on TV and every time I cry mm-hmm that's
so funny Kim Kardashian's our queen
Donald Trump is our present this is
American American 2004 you're Joe Mallya
do you think you're gonna have loyalty
Mele - yeah it's us is every instant
it's the JK Empire that's it
the Jamali everybody or maybe we could
just all be family somehow citizens and
all North Korea where it's like a PEZ
we're all at the top and we all make it
and then everyone else is like just like
[ __ ] as hell hmm maybe like a little
bit of that Plus old Greek Sparta and
you know just add it all feudal Japan
yeah let's just add it all up it's like
the whole thing where it's like it's
like gum I heard that you were immoral
and so we look everyone tells on
everyone like that kind of thing
nah it's it's it'll be like it'll be
like how it is right now yeah it would
just be like having fun and then it's
just yeah we'll have like fun little
games where we attract bad people take
America okay and then it'll be like the
invitation like hey guys
free playground like come along petals I
didn't know be like oh yeah and then we
just burned them nice yeah
what if it's just kind of like swings
it's like I just wanted to swing on the
swings a little bit kids playing there
too and it's like free kids stuff like
that yeah yeah we baked them by having
kids there in a playground oh no the
kids are at all the yeah yeah I was just
picturing like a van rolling by mm and
the door opens and it's a little kid and
now the pedo
is like oh [ __ ] that's what I usually do
this kid turns me on so the kid jumps in
the press in another world and then we
capture this pedal yep that's how we
have a helicopter with a magnet on like
great takes the van right and just
scoops right up in this
and it goes into the volcano perfect
with the kid and the kid we will get him
out someone yeah they'll be your
ejection seat just for the kids there
you go yeah
[Music]
[Music]